I'm Jordan Klepper at the opposition and
I know you've seen this today Dick's
Sporting Goods has caved to the Liberals
and will no longer carry assault weapons
or sell guns to people under 21 you hear
that dicks has gone soft
it used to be a rock hard Second
Amendment Ally and now expect us to just
play with their balls and other sporting
equipment no way and yet their stock is
up and has been up for more than four
hours they should call someone
those pricks I'm furious now that Dick's
is no longer they might as well be
firing blanks and they're not alone all
of these companies have also shafted gun
owners and paved the way for Dick's to
us frankly they should all be
sacked because I've loved Dick's my
entire life but not anymore that's hard
for me to swallow opposers are there any
three words more exciting than click and
subscribe
yes Hillary shot Lincoln subscribe now
and find out the truth they don't want
you to know and by day I mean losers
looking for YouTube handouts without
clicking subscribe do it